[Music]
his face is recognized all over the
world
the young medical student who became a
revolutionary icon
but was che guevara a heroic champion of
the poor
or a ruthless warlord who left a legacy
of repression
order order hey where have i seen that
guy before
ahem your honor this is ernesto che
guevara
in the early 1950s he left behind a
privileged life as a medical student
in argentina to travel through rural
latin america
the poverty and misery he witnessed
convinced him that saving lives
required more than medicine so he became
a terrorist
seeking to violently overthrow the
region's governments
what the region's governments were
brutal oligarchies
colonialism may have formally ended but
elites still controlled all the wealth
american corporations bought up land
originally seized from indigenous people
and used it for profit and export even
keeping most of it
uncultivated while locals starved
couldn't they vote to change that oh
they tried your honor in 1953
che came to guatemala under the
democratically elected government of
president arbenz
our bans passed reforms to redistribute
some of this uncultivated land
back to the people while compensating
the landowners
but he was overthrown in a cia-sponsored
coup
the military was protecting against the
seizure of private property
and communist takeover they were
protecting corporate profits
and chase saw that they would use the
fear of communism to overthrow
any government that threatened those
prophets so he took the lessons of
guatemala with him to mexico
there he met exiled cuban
revolutionaries and decided to help them
liberate their country you mean help
fidel castro turn a vibrant cuba
into a dictatorship dictatorship was
what cuba had before the revolution
fulgencio batista was a tyrant who came
to power
in a military coup he turned havana into
a luxury playground for foreigners
while keeping cubans mired in poverty
and killing
thousands in police crackdowns even
president kennedy called it the worst
example
of economic colonization humiliation
and exploitation in the world whatever
batista's faults it can't compare to the
totalitarian nightmare
castro would create forced labor camps
torture of prisoners
no freedom to speak or to leave but this
isn't the trial of fidel castro
is it che guevara was instrumental in
helping castro seize power
as a commander in his guerrilla army he
unleashed a reign of terror
across the countryside killing any
suspected spies
or dissenters he also helped peasants
build health clinics and schools taught
them to read
and even recited poetry to them his
harsh discipline was necessary against a
much stronger enemy
who didn't hesitate to burn entire
villages suspected of aiding the rebels
let's not forget that the new regime
held mass executions
and killed hundreds of people without
trial as soon as they took power in
1959.
the executed were officials and
collaborators who had tormented the
masses under batista
the people supported this revolutionary
justice
which people an angry mob crying for
blood
does not a democracy make and that's not
even mentioning
the forced labor camps arbitrary arrests
and repression of lgbt people that
continued long
after the revolution there's a reason
people kept risking their lives to flee
often with nothing but the clothes on
their backs so was that all this
che brought to cuba just another violent
dictatorship
not at all he oversaw land
redistribution helped establish
universal education and organized
volunteer literacy brigades that raised
cuba's literacy rate to 96
still one of the highest in the world
which allowed the government to control
what information everyone received
guevara's idealistic incompetence as
finance minister caused massive drops in
productivity when he replaced worker pay
raises
with moral certificates he suppressed
all press freedom
declaring that newspapers were
instruments of the oligarchy
and it was he who urged castro to host
soviet nuclear weapons
leading to the cuban missile crisis that
brought the world to the brink of
destruction
he was a leader not a bureaucrat that's
why he eventually left to spread the
revolution abroad
which didn't go well he failed to rally
rebels in the congo and went to bolivia
even when the soviets disapproved the
bolivian government with the help of the
cia
was able to capture and neutralize this
terrorist
in 1967 before he could do much damage
while doing plenty of damage themselves
in the process
so that was the end of it not at all as
chase said the revolution is immortal
he was publicly mourned in cities all
over the world
not by the cubans who managed to escape
and his story would inspire young
activists
for generations to come ha a trendy
symbol of rebellion
for those who never had to live under
his regime symbols of revolution may
become commodified
but the idea of a more just world
remains
maybe but i'm not sharing my coffee
che guevara was captured and executed by
government forces
in bolivia his remains would not be
found for another 30 years
but did he die a hero or had he already
become
a villain and should revolutions be
judged by their ideals
or their outcomes these are the
questions we face
when we put history on trial this video
is made possible by our community on
patreon and if you liked this video
check out more videos
in the history verses series in this
[Music]
playlist